[Music]
it's one of my favorite poi illusions
how do you add isolations to your
flowers and body tracers drex here from
drexfactor poi sharing with you the love
of boy spinning and flow arts to benefit
your body and brain and today we're
going to dive into a cool effect that
you can throw onto your poi flowers
before we dive in i just want to give a
quick shout out to the friends of the
channel big thanks to dark monk flow
fests flow toys juggling calling
pyroterra light toys spin balls and
ultra poi for helping to make the videos
on this channel possible you can learn
more about all of these amazing
businesses and what they're doing to
support flow artists like yourself by
checking out the links that i have down
in the description of this video and
special thanks to non-business friends
of the channel johnny howard elaine
machinski and becca fekonen thank you so
very much for your support for my work
and my mission isolations are one of the
most visually stunning and distinctive
poi tricks out there the ways in which
they create a hypnotic relationship
between the poi are really hard to miss
to say nothing of the gravity-defying
nature of them but what if i told you
that you could get this same effect in a
totally unrelated trick like say
a poi flower or body tracer in this
tutorial i'll show you how you can add
this effect to many of your favorite
flower based poi tricks the good news is
that this is an effect that's more of an
illusion than anything else so it
doesn't actually require you to know how
to perform isolations in order to get
any of them down so let's start off with
some groundwork namely how do you make a
thing look like in isolation when it's
really not in isolation one way is with
linear isolations when we have them
working in split time same direction and
wall plane we can create a moment if
just for an instant that certainly looks
like an isolation when we swap our poi
in and out of that center position the
key here is that we're looking for a
moment when the poi can overlap and we
can hang onto it for just a half a
second longer than normal our eyes are
already primed to see this kind of
relationship so if we can make it last
just a hair longer it really seems to
pop but how do we do that the key is two
tools that you might actually be
familiar with already static spin and in
spin flowers static spin is really just
poi jargon for having the hand post up
in one location and spin the poi there
in wall plane this can be done straight
in front of you off to one side with
your hand perched up on your shoulder it
all depends in spin flowers on the other
hand are those poi tricks where you're
moving both the hand and poi around in a
huge circle and you let the poi take a
beat round the hand at one or more
points in the course of its path
i usually play around with one two or
even four petal inspin flowers on the
regular okay so how do we take these two
components and turn them into something
that includes that isolated moment we're
going to start with an example that i
like to think of as an isolated windmill
a standard windmill follows the regular
pattern of having each hand and poi
complete one beat in front of the body
as well as one beat behind the native
shoulder that is the shoulder a given
hand and poi are connected to one way
you can actually think of a windmill
especially the big broader ones that are
sometimes dubbed poitruvian man is as
both hands performing a single petal
inspin flower with that single petal at
the very top of the hand path and to
isolate it we're going to train two
individual positions before putting them
together here's how to start one of your
hands is going to have to hang out
performing a static spin behind its
native shoulder this can sometimes be
challenging in itself so perform this in
front of a mirror if you're able to next
you're going to get your other hand
performing a one petal inspin flower and
place that petal right above the
opposite hand the result you get that
nice isolation when you perform that
flower petal you can actually stretch
out that pedal just a little bit to make
that effect really pop here's how
imagine you're actually going to stall
the poi performing the flower right at
the point of the opposite hand and at
the last minute pull it back out to
complete its flower path that faint into
a stall helps slow down the poi for a
moment and it really draws out the shape
of the isolation even more see if you
can keep this going for 10 reps of the
inspin flower i know it's hard with that
one hand spinning behind your shoulder
but trust me it'll be worth it once you
have the one shoulder down it's time to
try out the other shoulder swap out the
action each hand was performing the hand
that was doing the static spin is now
doing the flower and vice versa once
again work to synchronize that flower
petal to the static spin hand and use a
stalling motion to stretch the moment
out once you have both shoulders unlock
work to perform them in sequence do this
by performing the flower petal and
shoulder static spin combo on one side
of the body three times then switch to
doing it three times on the other side
of the body
now work your way down to doing two reps
on one side and the other before finally
going down to only one rep on each side
eureka a windmill with isolated elements
really you can use this technique to add
isolated moments to nearly any flower or
body tracer you come up with here are
some examples that i'm fond of
personally first up a five beat weave
fountain that isolates above and beneath
each shoulder as it travels around the
body
next up the isolated body tracer i
learned in the ryan duchamp challenge
contains elements of this too see if you
can spot where i'm switching back and
forth between the static spin and the
inspin flower
and finally check out this cool
variation on a crosser hybrid once again
add a pedal to what's usually an
extension and see how the pieces line up
there are plenty more examples out there
and i'm sure you all will find tons of
applications for this idea yourselves
too post your work to social media and
make sure to tag me so i can get
inspired by your risks on this concept
[Music]
did you get anything out of this video
please make sure to like comment share
and subscribe to help other people find
it and to help my channel grow this
video would not be possible if not for
the wonderful support of all of these
amazing people right here these are my
flow patrons over on patreon and they
along with the people listed down in the
description helped to make this video
and all the videos on my channel
possible thank you one and all for your
support do you like my videos do you
like my flow sessions vlogs reviews
combos and more i'm on a mission to
bring poi spinning and flow arts to the
wider world and help people connect with
their bodies and their brains so help me
do it head on over to patreon.com
drexfactorpoi and sign up you can do
that at the link in the description or
the card that just popped up if you're
watching on youtube
there you can get access to a whole host
of rewards and help me along in my
mission do check that out please and
thank you what are some cool and
counter-intuitive ways you've found to
create these isolated moments in your
own spinning leave me a comment and let
me know i'll include a link to a
playlist of other tutorials like this
one down in the description or up on
screen if you're watching this video on
youtube make sure to get outside the
flow today and i'll see you with a new
video on friday thanks for watching and
have a good one
peace